so you are a
21-year-old multi-millionaire you're an
Ecom
entrepreneur um you've generated over
eight figures through Dr uh through Drop
Shipping through um mentorship agency
work that's phenomenal you're only 21
yeah that's the title of it right so
okay so I I want to go back and
understand you know you have all of this
stuff you know you're buying watches I
saw your new Rolex yeah Tiffany op yeah
it's stunning um oh yeah Tiffany op no
it's stunning you have all this stuff
but like you're 21 yeah so talk to me
about the Journey of how you got here
cuz from what I understand you dropped
out of school at 16 yeah so I actually
dropped out I have like my middle school
diploma I'll always joke around with
people about it's the the technical like
final years of my life was nth grade
that was like the final year I left
school yeah um that nth grade year
completed it and then into sophomore
year I just I knew it wasn't for me and
I really didn't know what I would do I
think a lot of guys on my situation they
they love to say they dropped out and
instantly like figured out it just
wasn't the case for me those first two
years like really were like kind of lost
for me and I was figuring stuff out but
I just was trying like everything I knew
it was possible I saw and we were like I
think a lot of people when they
initially start they they see the light
through something and I saw it my older
brother he was already working hustling
and I was like you know why can't I do
it and uh yeah that that's 16 to 18
right when I left school I was a little
party boy in like sophomore year so they
they loved that I was leaving cuz I was
getting a lot of uh people in my grade
like influenced to party and stuff so
they kind of just like kicked me out and
I remember driving home at a Honda Civic
I bought myself and I drove home at 16 I
was like I'm done and I never stepped
foot in school again and that was like
kind of the start you know what's so
funny is it's always the people that
drop out of school were a nuisance in
school you know sounds like you were
influencing people to party I was bad
there you go so it's always those people
that end up doing so much better than
everyone else
but you said the first two years you
struggled yeah and then you and then you
you made your first millionaire at like
17 18 17 okay 17 so how how did you do
that talk me through it what were you
doing and how and how did you struggle
like what did you fail at yeah so that
those first like two years I'd say it's
the first like clump of time in my life
of kind of like real adult life where I
was out of school and I I didn't mean to
do it I didn't really do it for like the
flex of it I wasn't posting about it but
I was just alone I was like isolated I
didn't talk to people from my schol cuz
they're all in they're in sophomore
Junior and Senior year so we're just
living a bit of different lives and I
dabbled in a few different business
models I tried like the whole stock
trading penny stocks with uh Ricky
utierre I remember trying Forex and what
really initially was like the first
business business was Drop Shipping
although it didn't work like I started a
summer store in summer of 2018 it's
called Summer Necessities selling pool
floaties failed sunglasses store called
sunglasses for Less failed and then my
third business I won't say the name
because I don't want you guys to find
the uh info on me but it was a store
selling airpods and I was selling them
as Apple earpods as like kind of replica
airpods and they just crushed it
literally it wasn't even difficult and
at 17 I was like I had I think my record
month was like 65 Grand I was pushing 5
10 grand days some days and I pretty
much went like a year straight and I was
just pushing that like you know 40 60
Grand a month range and around a year
and a half in it was working really well
for me I was making money until I
realized like you can't sell counterfeit
products and apple knock knock knock
they gave me a nice knock in the door uh
and a lawyer I remember it wasn't a
lawyer I guess it was a like a server or
something he served me my papers their
was I was a minor and since I was
17 they couldn't really do much and they
just made me shut it down and I was good
but I know guys who got supreme Patty
he's one guy he got some major
consequences from it and they go and
they ask for Revenue they say if you did
5 million we want x amount in Damages so
so Apple tried to sue you when you were
17 years old they threatened to pursue
litigation if I didn't shut down the
site so let let's just get into that in
case you know it's not clear you you
were selling airpods but replica airpods
yeah I was so they were black white red
and but everybody does that I see that
everywhere yeah the thing people don't
see is that when you do like slightly
sketchy it might work for shortterm
but longterm you're okay and that
was my thing like so it was cool for me
cuz I was like I needed that you know at
17 like that's 16 to 17 I kind of was
just figuring out and then it was
around a year after dropping out I
dropped out right when I turned 16
pretty much um it was this is early
2019 that's when was hitting and I
even I posted on Instagram yesterday a
screenshot of me like freaking out like
super young and of like a $1,500 day
like 2cent cost per clicks it was a
different world back then but yeah that
like 2019 year is where Drop Shipping
really solidified for me and it just
kind of like really gave me the footing
of it it never really clicked but I
think it just slowly faded to I realized
like okay making millions online isn't
hard and yeah it it wasn't how did you
okay so how did you discover that you
could make millions online because the
reality is you only know what you see
right and I'm sure your parents weren't
making money online Drop Shipping You
Know You're So Young so how did you know
that drop shipping was something that
you could do I think for me it was
always just how I'm going to do it not
if it was possible and I think Drop
Shipping was the first Avenue where I
was like okay this is like a way to do
it you know I just it was super simple
in the beginning where I just knew if I
ran ads I spent $100 I'd make back like
400 in revenue and I was like pretty
dumb I I won't sit here and B
like I was a young genius I wasn't I was
pretty stupid I was jeweling all day
like I'm I'm 17 I was ripping McDonald's
I was a big McDonald's guy was younger
and it just goes to show in my eyes like
if I had 17 figured it out and I was
like really beginner basic dude there
weren't the resources there are now
online but it kind of just clicked and I
remember literally it was just I had
like probably 10 grand to my name when I
first started and it was as simple as
like increasing ad spend Revenue went up
with it I was just fulfilling the orders
actually when I hired my Now assistant
cholie she's been with me for like 5
years now I hired her to fulfill orders
and do customer support and yeah just
almost like 10x and 100x it went from
like 10K to a million bucks so so how
much were you making at 1718 dude I mean
that end of that year I think I took an
actual like tax gain of like 240 Grand
profit okay and I did about a billion
bucks Revenue that 2019 early 2020 you
know what really blows my mind the fact
that there's this world of 16 to 23y
olds who are making millions online
whether it's through Drop Shipping
crypto and I just it just blows my mind
I mean you mentioned your older brother
but he's not that much older he's what
three years older he's three years older
than you how you just got to you got to
get exposed to it right that was like I
think one of my biggest advantages when
I was young is I got a bit lucky with
being exposed to him but even now like
the the Elon musks in the world and
stuff like that always say it and people
like some people laugh at it but I think
it's really true it's it's not that
crazy what they did
anyone who's under 27 right now when
musk was under 27 he was in a worst spot
he was accumulating debt so if you
dropped out of college you're already at
least even if you're broke you've zero
at least you're not in debt and to think
that musk at 27 was like I think it was
400 Grand in debt and he was able to 3
years later PayPal 100 million so you
just realize that it it really isn't
difficult and I think it's more so
realizing it's possible and that's where
in my knowledge consumption I wish I
started sooner with that and starting to
realize holy like holy what's
possible and even now like you know
we'll get to it but this year and I just
got an offer from my Agency for over
seven Figures it's it's it's crazy do
you think there's any drawbacks to
making that much money at such a young
age I I've talked about it before I mean
that that 16 to 18 for me was sad like
it wasn't like fun I was making money I
got my first Rolex like at 17 but it it
wasn't uh normal and I didn't realize
that at the time and I think it started
hitting me when I was like 19 2020 I
moved out officially all my friends left
my hometown I was like like this is
depressing let me leave they were at
College yeah College Normal stuff and I
was like it let me get a beach
apartment Grant did a 5 cam mon
apartment on the beach Florida yeah in
Sunny Isles and this was a great move
too cuz it exposed me some really
successful people I bought a Tesla at
this time too a nice like performance
Tesla but where it really was hitting me
was that I was just super alone and I
think it built a really good introverted
side to myself or even now to this day I
mean you know Kier he's been with me for
a while I can go a month straight just
not leaving my place really yeah I even
now I don't I don't do much you don't
leave ever I mean I what about groceries
like I I have a chef I assistant house
cleaners every day I mean all this stuff
in my life now like the basic stuff's
automated really the only time I leave
is maybe to go to like a dinner um big
dating guy I go out and go on a lot of
dates but yeah for me it was always just
really alone and I think it it it's a
skill I've not built like I could be
alone no problem I can go I travel alone
I went to Europe for a month alone and
yeah I'm a big believer in isolation is
one of the biggest keys to just
hyperfocus and it almost happened
naturally that 16 to 18 well I also
think that not a lot of people are on
that grind you know they're not on the
hustle especially at such a young age
you know everybody just wants to party
and have fun and drink and smoke or
whatever it is and so naturally that
will distract you yeah I mean I think
it's another thing when you're exposed
to the right people people I I hate it's
I think it's a little cheesy the whole
like your net worth your network is your
net worth I don't I don't like I don't
like those cheesy lines but but it's
true it's true I just I don't like how
it's put I believe that who you expose
yourself to on a consistent basis is
like who you're going to be influenced
by you know every human whether you
believe it or not has their own
self-interest in their mind so every
human wants what they need the most and
I think the only time it kind of goes
away is like family mother son times
like that where you know the mother will
die for the kid but for me I'm I'm doing
everything to make my life better even
my best best best friend it's the same
thing he wants his good life I want my
good life um and when you realize that
you realize realiz that if you're around
the wrong people they're just going to
influence you towards their life and if
their life's shitty you're going to be
influenced towards a shitty life like if
someone can't afford to spend you know
15 grand to Charter a jet they like want
to go fly domestic like it's just it's
it's not ideal and it starts shrinking
your perspective I think a little bit
but I sat down at a dinner and this is
when it really hit me guy's worth like
130 mil he just actually did a huge
company and I chatted with this guy for
three hours in Monaco and where it
really hit me was that he just thought
so big and he's not that old and I just
I love that I love the idea of
just like insane optimism and
realization to what's possible and yeah
I think that's one of the biggest things
that's led to so much success for me I
just I really know like how much is
possible it's just insane yeah that's
one of the great things about being here
in Miami you surrounded by Hustlers
hustle culture um I mean I know you
spend a lot of time by yourself but do
you feel um do you feel that hustle
culture do you feel that pressure to
constantly you know get up work hit the
spot like whatever it is just to be on
top of your grind all the time you have
chefs are they making like the best type
of foods for you I'm weird with it I I
look at productivity as inversing it I
inverse productivity and look at what
isn't productivity for me you know the
idea of being productive is having a
high output and having in high output
for me is getting a lot of work done to
hopefully make a lot of money so for me
I don't look at it as much as how can I
get a lot done I more look at it as what
are all the things that would keep me
from working and how the do I get
that out of my life right now it's like
it's quite insan saying how like
systemized my life is so you remove
anything which which distracts you
basically I have a dog walker 1,500 a
month I pay her she walks my dog three
times a day wow so she and they it's to
the extent if she has access to my unit
I could literally be asleep and she'll
come in my dog will run down go with her
it just in my eyes I I don't look at it
as a whole like look at your hourly and
then replace it if it's not worth your
time I just look at it as like you don't
want to do low Roi stuff and it's made
it that now I just have such a high
output yeah I always tell my team and I
tell people around me it's so hard for
me not to win and that's why it's it's
it's almost just inevitable for me you
know my mom and dad I think they don't
fully understand it I'm very confident
I'll buy a play next year I'm very
confident in that and people they might
look at it and laugh now think like oh
he probably has a few million dollars to
his name but me having 25 30 million out
of next year is very doable and then I
buy a little plane get my name on it
what kind of plane you on out of nothing
czy probably a Phenom 300 was like four
or five mil yeah well you make it okay
so you bring up a really interesting
topic about your parents not
understanding it and I think that is one
of most relatable things to any
entrepreneur but any particularly any
young entrepreneur so to what extent
have your parents understood what you're
doing and also how much pressure have
you had from them you obviously you
dropped out of school you obviously
didn't go to university college so how
they sort of let you do your own thing
at such a young age so super young like
right when I left school the deal was
with my mom specifically my dad's always
been in the picture and I I love my
family to death thank god um just my
parents are divorced so I wasn't around
my dad as much as a kid and it was more
so a deal deal with my mom and I told
her I want to make I want to go out and
start working and I'll make 50 grand net
in 6 months if I don't I said I'll go
back to school and like if you think
about it and I'm not an advocate for
dropping out maybe college but high
school it's a little sketchy but I in my
head and I stand behind this it it would
have just been 6 months behind you know
if it failed I would have like okay go
back to school I'm a semester back I
didn't really care to have to go back a
year and it didn't have to happen
thankfully you know I think I ended it
like right around must have been like 44
45k okay and she never even brought it
up she saw my bank account you 5K short
yeah she saw my bank account till I had
at least like a few hundred grand then I
remember kicking her off cuz she was
getting a bit stressed but for my mom my
dad and it really hit me last year in
June I had like a kind of like I
wouldn't say a depressed moment I don't
really believe in depression as much as
I was just sad and it was because I
didn't really have anyone to talk to I
still think most people around me don't
really know what I'm dealing with and I
was specifically was talking to my mom
and she really was like worried for me
CU at this point I mean this is when I
started really cracking like six figure
months and I was doing 100 to 300K
months and with that comes some
craziness you know between tax planning
the numbers when you start looking out a
year you know $4 $5 million in a year it
just starts getting stressful and she
was still aware of it and I just that's
when I decided to completely just cut
off my mom and my dad on a financial
basis where I just didn't look at them
ever on advice for financial stuff CU I
realize that them and most people just
don't see it they don't get it you know
this year I'll probably clear like 5 six
million bucks Top Line and I mean it's
it's 10 10 times what they've what
they've done in a year so it's just hard
and it's one of the drawbacks I think is
when you start doing really crazy things
there's less and less people that you
can kind of like relate to and
ultimately friends in my eyes are people
that you relate to so it's you lose
friends yeah you do um you said that
your parents didn't really understand
what you were dealing with what were you
dealing
with I think that I lost some purpose um
I lost some purpose and even like I
think I'm at a similar spot cuz you know
I think when you're initially chasing
like a million doll a million dollar
liquid I think is a really big number I
think 100K liquid it's like not that
crazy but a million liquids like you
feel powerful right it's just very hard
I mean your your borderline set if you
have a decent business or in my case
three that are all producing good income
and also you have a ton of money in the
bank I think you almost have an epiphany
and for me that's what happened where I
was chasing Financial Security I think
for so long in abundance and then mid
last year I remember thinking like is
this what it's all about and I don't
believe in the guys money doesn't matter
money isn't happiness I'm like cool like
yeah you can have happiness and you can
have money like have both but I do
definitely believe in there's a bigger
picture purpose in chasing and that's
when I really started liking the idea of
building with people I really started
thinking team building but yeah people
just don't get it now my biggest thing
is I just I like really being
intelligent so my whole thing is
knowledge consumption last year I've
probably read like 20 books wow and I'm
I'm really trying to get to the point I
could read a book a week that's like
it's it's very hard for me I have very
bad uh Focus issues so reading I
normally have to get out after like 20
30 pages but I I mean anyone watching
this like the easiest how to get rich
101 is like read a lot of books it's so
hard to not get really rich if you do
that it really is it's like difficult do
you have a favorite book yeah uh I would
say who not how I read that like a month
ago I think that book when you have more
than a few hundred kid your name and a
team reading that book like 10x is your
output because you realize that hard
work and hustle that whole hustle
culture we were mentioning that isn't
the goal everyone glorifies like let me
be the hardest worker let me wake up at
3:00 a.m. I was this guy a year ago
that's what I was preaching and then you
realize like if I just have a
person on my team who's just as
intelligent as me maybe even more
intelligent 10 years older than me my my
oldest guy on my team is now like 34 M
if someone who has 13 years of life on
me is also waking up at 3:00 a.m. I
could just not wake up at 3:00 a.m. and
then that same output's coming from him
and then what can I do with my time now
and that's where I realized that the
true factor for me is I don't even need
to do anything all I need to do is make
really good decisions and have a really
good brain on my shoulders and that's
that's all I'm doing now yeah you know
Kier even sees with me almost every day
probably now 80% of my calendar is just
open and 5 months ago my was
crazy I was I was
working so hard and it was really when
it synced in that it's not like the
hustle culture that works it's really
removing all the and then you
just have time to do what you know you
need to do mhm and you said that you
came to
Florida with I think it was $40,000 or
something in the bank yeah so we
understand now okay you made a lot of
money with Drop Shipping when you were
17 but how did you make all of this that
you have like you came to Florida with
40,000 how long ago was that by the way
like two three years ago I I moved from
I was already in Florida I moved an hour
south oh Sunny is so I moved to Sunny
Isles and that was like my first big
decision I only had like I probably had
like six seven months of rent when when
I went there I remember paying taxes the
first year I paid taxes I got I
didn't understand how much did you pay
in taxes I want to say it was like 80
grand but the issue was is that I didn't
like 80 grand in taxes and what the
up part was that I think it was
240,000 in in like AGI aggress adjusted
gross income which means like what you
took home after all expenses the issue
is is that I took home a lot less like
there were stuff that I missed deducting
and pretty much I overpaid in taxes a
ton which is fine you didn't get the
money back shout out the IRS no I mean I
didn't have a good CPA like last year
either or I'm I'm not too big on looking
back and dwelling on but as that
first year taxes me so I didn't
have that much money and mind you Apple
just also shut me down so going to
moving out in that 18 on us 18 I did a
million bucks in Revenue but after
everything after my Rolex cars all this
I only had probably 50 60 Grand and
it was moving to Sunny I started opening
up my brain a bit but that's where I
started now doing higher level higher uh
level things that's when I got into Tik
Tok that was a huge thing for me
cuz courses like that year year and a
half I did probably a million bucks
million what were you doing on Tik Tok
posting the whole like you know young
selling young yeah I was like the young
kid with the Tesla in a beach house I
was like I feel like I pioneered the
whole like Drop Shipping Tik Tok space
there was no one doing it what were you
what were you selling on Tik Tok so
initially I was just posting videos my
mom was the one who said like you have a
cool story post a Tik Tok right and I
did and it did really well I was like
damn this is sick like 60 I think it was
like 60,000 views my my first Tik Tok
still out there now I have like 1 Point
1.7 or 8 mil and yeah I started I
remember I had 100K quite quick and had
guys reaching out to like pay me and I
was like what the this is weird and
I'm still like trying to figure out Drop
Shipping this is also I have a YouTube
video I started YouTube I started a new
store and I posting that so I'm like
Drop Shipping and doing Tik Tok and
that's when I realized like holy
I'm not going to have these guys pay me
to help them I'm going to have them pay
me for a course and I built out a course
it was so in the beginning it was
300 bucks but I was selling them like
water it was it I I think one day I had
it tracked cuz we were my assistant was
in my DMs and I had another friend who I
was paying so it was me my assistant and
that friend and I think one day we had
11,000 dmms inbound and it's you can
imagine it's just I was this young super
naive kid and every 15 to 17-year-old
like loved me because they're like holy
sh he's like doing like he has the Tesla
I had it wrapped in a purple and it was
that 220 year I really like did well on
Tik Tok I got to like 400k and Drop
Shipping also picked up pretty well I
ran like a few pump and dump stores
probably netted like 150 200k from Drop
Shipping but the coaching and course is
what really hit issue I didn't realize
is that that was not sustainable as it
just wasn't like fun to go and publicize
a course that's why like 2021 is the
year I really think I started like
adulting I moved to a building in Bickle
Panorama great building got a super high
floor I felt like a beast 81st floor and
it was that year I think I really like
grew up a lot I started my first real
brand it's a fitness brand brand a lot
of you guys might have seen it um but
that brand now has done well over seven
figures and that's like a brand I
eventually want to sell I got an offer
for like 250k I turned down uh just cuz
I I really do want to build it the one
thing I don't want is to be the guy who
stopped Drop Shipping I really don't
need to do it anymore I think my agency
right now is my highest lever thing but
I do it just for the fun of it it really
is enjoyable for me well I hear a lot of
people say that drop shipping's dead is
it dead saturation isn't real that's one
thing I've realized and it's actually it
is real saturation I don't I mean
saturation I think saturation is real
but the idea of it's it's not like an
onoff button of like okay the light
switch is on saturation is there it
doesn't work it's almost like saturation
is a level and the more saturated
something is the harder it will be but I
think also the proof of concept that it
works you know you could say being a
real estate agent saturated but it
people make a ton of money doing it and
I think when something is saturated it's
a really green light to be like do this
but you also if there's a lot of people
doing it you have to look for a way to
kind of cut the line mhm I don't know
about you guys like I I always give the
analogy of at an amusement park there's
people waiting in a line you could
finesse around it you can go to the
front pay the guy 20 bucks and
you just skip the whole line Thousand
other people are waiting so that's how I
look at most business models no matter
how saturated it is you have to pursue
things you have a Competitive Edge at
and that's even like how I live life but
that 2021 moving to Brickle and I've
been here three years although I've
changed spots a few times that was where
I started my main brand started my
agency and my coaching courses I kind of
got rid of courses and went into the
mentorship world I got a lot more
selective still taking on a good amount
of people I've got very very selective
nowadays um but that's where things
started getting good cuz then I was
actually the person helping people I
didn't really use a course as much and
yeah that idea of coaching Tik Tok
agency and Drop Shipping was just a
lethal combo to get me to seven
figures do you think anyone can do can
do what you've done yeah I don't think
I'm special in any way I think if
anything there's a lot of fuckups I made
like if if you just watch every YouTube
video I have now you would probably do
exactly what I did way faster um what's
the biggest mistake that you've
done I think that
I I did things too fast I think that
speed is important but there were
certain things that I didn't need to do
fast that I did and it led to it going
bad like what I I did a an nft to my
student base and I did an nft I remember
thinking we would do like a quarter Mill
and it was like fine I would do like six
months of coaching with it had a good
deliverable around it and we did it I
remember I think it did 35 Grand and I
was like I just spent like 50 Grand
on this thing hired a whole Team all the
we lost money and now I have 35
Grand of people that are expecting
and I was in this bad Epiphany I was
like this I just refunded them all
like I'm not doing this yeah and I I
remember reflecting off that and that
was one of the lower points that was uh
mid of like 2022 and that was when I had
this like sadish moment where I was like
damn like what am I doing like what is
life right now cuz I was kind of I was
probably taking in like 50 100 people
and mentoring a month um I my Drop
Shipping brand took off in 2021 I did
400 Grand in Q4 of that year
all of 2022 I mean even now we're we're
getting into supplements now it's so
things were going well like 20 I was 20
at the time I have a very solid amount
of money I'm living in this like dream
apartment I I impulsed four months later
I bought the lambo but I had a great
Tesla and I think people would think
that's like the picturesque life but in
my head I was like I was going through
it and that's when I think I really did
some deep diving in like what I want
longterm and that's when I fell in love
with learning and that's why like now
I'm just I'm a big learner like I can I
love the idea I'm going uh to Daytona up
north literally solo this weekend
actually I'm going to look at some real
estate there but bigger picture I
literally am probably just going to like
sit on the beach with like two books and
just try to like speed read both
of them that day I just that's like my
hype now I love that so going too fast
has been like the biggest mistake 100%
what's the biggest lesson that you've
learned and the best thing that you've
done I think I had a guy last night I
had some buddy one friend from my
hometown he really wanted wanted to see
my apartment I haven't seen him like 6
months so I let him come and he brought
two friends actually two guys and they
they all came and these guys were like
in awe they're like freaking the
out they're like dude I don't understand
this place I mean to give you reference
one of them has a business I think he
said he's done like 20K in last year so
it's like it's night and day and he
asked me when he was LE I drove them to
a club I didn't want to go but I drove
them there cuz I felt bad and I bring
them in the UR we're driving they're
like freaking out I'm gunning it and he
said to me as all my friends got out but
he waited and I really admired this I
thought it was interesting it was one of
those like let me help this guy moments
and he came up to my door and he said
like what's one piece of advice you'd
give me and I'm like what's your
business it's he helps people in uh he
does like soccer training it's so it's
trippy but I said just like find people
who've done really well doing what you
do and copy them yeah it really
I think getting to seven and eight
figures is not trying to reinvent the
wheel and then right when your neck and
neck towards your competitors that's
where you go and you're like okay what's
one unique advantage and doing that 10
times and then you just beat them
so that's my thing the biggest thing now
I use and a huge lesson is I I
copy the out of people when I see
they're working if I see someone's going
and running a really good marketing
campaign Tik Tok shop is a great example
everyone's talking about Tik Tok shop if
you're an Ecom do Tik Tok shop it's like
so simple yet a lot of people sit out
there and they're burning four hours a
day like I don't know going to lunches
and starting a Tik Tok Shop store
it's so easy yet so many people won't do
it yeah and I'll always use the example
of water every human on this planet
knows to drink a lot of water yet
there's tons of people who don't and
it's like such a basic thing that people
don't do and it makes you realize okay
people are just people are
literally just not thinking what's best
for them and people make a lot of bad
decisions and I love that it's just such
an easy way to win so I just I look at
it as just making a lot of good
decisions and the easiest way to know
what good decisions to make is to look
at people who are beating you because
they made more good decisions well
that's the thing cuz people always sort
of shy away from copying but if it works
there's no point Reinventing the whe
just keep doing it that's my now
especially cuz I'm taking on a lot less
people into my mentorship we charging a
lot more and I have a pretty like severe
interview process people come in I'll
literally tell them like the first step
I give them a store I build him a site
and then I say okay let's find your top
five competitors and what the are
we going to copy from them yeah like oh
is it illegal is it this is that I'm
like dude worry about making a
million dollars then worry about getting
sued it's a way better like combo don't
worry about getting sued now youle
example a a perfect um and yeah
I love the idea of that it just works I
mean even like every single successful
person ever and you'll look most of them
didn't reinvent the wheel yeah you know
the guys who did credit to them like
almost always they hit huge the Apple
the Amazon even the Tesla but you
realize it's just it's not necessary I
think when you initially start um I
think it's more so the game to passing
like the seven to eight and nine figures
I think getting to seven super easy to
not reinvent the wheel that's s to eight
jump and 8 to N I think is where you
really have to go and be different one
thing which I've um which I've learned
and I know you have a big opinion on
this is the idea of investing in
yourself with luxury items so a lot of
people say oh you know just cuz you have
all this money like doesn't mean you
have to you know buy watches and cars
but I saw you driving the other day in
your labo like I said you got a new
watch so why are you spending money and
why is that an investment rather than
just you know something to be flashy and
and show off about yeah I mean one of
the biggest flaws and I've actually told
us I love my mother to death I love her
I'm going to get her beach house but I
told this to her actually cuz I thought
it was very interesting and I always
whenever I talk to people I always try
to keep the conversation very intriguing
I like talking about deep it's just
me and I was telling her I was like you
know one real flaw that I when I'm older
and have kids I'm going to make sure I
don't do is I'm going to make sure I
don't think small right and I think that
when I was young and I I told to her in
a very polite way I think that I didn't
really realize what's possible and I
think for me specifically in my family
we grew up in a bit of a scarcity
mindset we got wrecked in like both of
the market crashes 01 and 08
so it just hurt my family and it made
them in a scarcity mindset they would
think they would think like uh secure be
safe like okay if we have like 100k like
try to minimize spending dude for me
like I I'm so like disgustingly
confident in myself I could genuinely go
and this is why I'm going to end up
probably buying a plane I really want to
buy Bugatti next year too I'm probably
going to pick but either or it's it's
it's not scary when you realize how
cheap it is this apartment is 20 grand
people like oh like it's a lot of money
then you realiz like how hard is it to
make an extra 20 grand and I could like
confidently say it is not I just turned
down a 140 Grand sponsorship
deal from Auto autod DS probably more it
was 140 base like 12K a month plus they
were giving me 30% of affiliate Revenue
right I turned it down cuz one past it
not doing anything for me that money
just the idea of me closing that deal it
was two hours I took one meeting with
them one followup meeting 140 Grand and
then you might say like oh I'm just
starting I can't make money that quick
it's like who made that rule mhm no one
made that rule that you can't make money
quick it's just something that's taught
to you and you have to look at what
subconscious things are in your brain
that are limiting you and for me it was
it was the scarcity mindset so I'm
really hardcore now on not being afraid
to spend money especially I don't look
at things that have a cost I look at
like almost the expense of having it
right so a lot of people will look at
partying as just like hey I have to
spend like 10 grand at a club I just
spent 8 and a half Grand of the club the
other night and some people look at the
initial cost that's one up but the
next up is like the next day you're
burned so however much you're going to
make that day is and then maybe
you had an opportunity that next day
that you missed out on and that was a
$500,000 deal in 10 years so I just look
at everything from the long-term effect
of it now and that's when you realize
like cars watches really
spending money on anything it's not that
scary especially watches these things
are like cheap you just pay
sales tax I can go flip this thing for
25 Grand tomorrow well that's the thing
actually and I only realized this about
watches recently that it's not I always
thought if you're buying an expensive
watch then then you're giving away the
money no but it's not it's literally an
investment like you could just get the
money back depending on the watch
obviously you're up and down 10% on the
good watches you're normally up or down
10% and I always you know what I
love I love when I see really rich
people buying like clothes really
expensive clothes buying like dumb
dude when I see them chartering a lot of
planes that Hypes me up cuz I'm like wow
this person's going to lose or at least
this is someone I could like
spit on grind to dust it's just so easy
to beat a person like that it actually
it literally fires me the up um um
and that's one thing I took from like
ovens and Alex Becker those are two guys
that look up to a ton both of them are
worth close to nine figures I know
Becker is worth over nine figures and
they're they love that they're just all
these little competitive edges they're
like they look at Kobe Bryant him and
Jordan are super great examples where
they weren't just born super
good at basketball no they got really
good they devoted their life to it they
were obviously genetically advantaged
towards it being like big tall Etc but
all in all you realize that it's just
like wow there's two identically tall
identically weight in regards like
Jordan has an identical replica that
just wasn't the greatest basketball
player of all time he isn't worth
billions of dollars and that's my thing
now whenever I'm spending money like I I
don't give a about all this little
because that's not what I'm worried
about I'm worried about like what
decision am I going to make tomorrow
that's going to lead to uh 7% growth in
my agency that's going to make us an
extra 200 Grand next year and that's the
thing now where I think I've gotten to
the point where just the small like
normal money doesn't matter too much to
me yeah well I also think it gives you a
lot of credibility right you know if you
something is simp is like tting up in a
Lambo tting up with a nice watch like it
does give you a lot of credibility and I
think and correct me if I'm wrong I
think especially because you're so young
people may not take you as seriously at
times so I I imagine you know being able
to show your accomplishments obviously
helps with your credibility so how do
you how do you handle you know people
not NE necessarily taking you seriously
and also you said that the oldest guy on
your team is like more than 10 years
older than you so how do you how do you
handle that so I actually it was when I
was doing interviews I my first real
interviews where I was like kind of
getting resumes and stuff now I have
someone on my team who handles it kind
of like a head of talent but I remember
doing an interview and a Like A
42-year-old gave me his resume I was
like holy I'm reading this guy's
resumee I've never even like looked or
thought to make a resume I'm a I
have the education level of a
16-year-old yeah and it just made me
realize that it's just it's not the game
even with the spending money Elon Musk
right now he could stop working or even
I'll use a better example cuz I think
musk is a he's like too advanced Iman
gosi I think is a great example
he now can stop working his team will
easily clear him probably 20 to 30
million a year if he works he'll
probably be able to push that to 50 60
cuz content and stuff but think of that
the 30 million what we'll call it 300
days in the year he can make pretty much
100 grand every day $100,000 every day
maybe 50% gross margins on that so he
can net 50 Grand a day doing nothing
yeah that's while you're going you're
working your ass off he can go and every
single day buy one of these spend and
probably do the nicest dinner in Miami
for breakfast launch lunch and dinner go
drop 10 grand on Louis Vuitton for some
random girl and still have 5 grand left
over how does that then with that 5
grand left over he rants the nicest
apartment in this building for
150,000 a month so you realize how much
money is out there I think and it's very
intriguing and for me that's my thing
with spending where I don't really look
at it as that nice I I really do right
now think that it's kind of like average
in my eyes that I have a Lambo I don't
think it's that crazy cuz I'm not
looking at myself and comparing myself
to a 21-year-old I really do want to
beat a guy like musk I like hate I hate
and what I love about those old
guys is I just know I have so much time
on them and I'm just thinking like on a
trajectory I I have calculations right
now to get to 100 million and I
literally calculate it in a spreadsheet
every single week I review it I I have
some crazy I'm a big spreadsheet guy um
I highly recommend you get into Excel
and spreadsheets and tracking your life
but I track my sleep my income my profit
and all that stuff and it it isn't a
maybe for me it's uh when and the when
will be determined on the decisions I
make and that's why it's so easy for me
to make a decisions is because because I
just it's like do I want to be worth
like 100 million or 30 or like 20
million I'd weigh rather than more so
yeah what's your timeline is it 100
million by 30 what's your timeline I
think I don't fully have that I know the
numbers I'm a I'm a big numbers guy
that's why I said I track in Excel I
don't know how I'm going to get to 100
Mil is I don't think it's going to be
from cash flow it's just going to take
too long um you know I I can cash flow
pretty well and I do pretty well but
it's not ideal to do it through cash
flow I think every guy pretty much I've
seen go from eight to nine figures it's
been through exit and Enterprise Value
so Luc anet's like kind of a mentor to
my to me I really like that guy he was
the one explaining it to me he's like
you know the first eight eight figures
first 10 mil you make I think is from
cash flow cash flow producing business
you take distributions You Take payroll
but I think the eight figures to nine
figures will be from an exit and I
really want to get into the world of
starting a software I just don't want to
do it yet I want to wait till I have
probably at least 10 million liquid and
at that point I think it'll almost be
like such a game for me and it'll be so
intelligent at that point it's just
again it'll be so hard for me to lose or
so hard for me to not win um um and yeah
so that's my game right now I'm trying
to cash flow to 10 to eight figures and
10 mil heavy in crypto I love crypto
right now well I was going to ask you
like what's your what's your background
with crypto cuz I know you mentioned NS
so crypto initially man I uh I'm a big
believer in the grass is greener where
you water it everyone says like oh
bitcoin's pumping like let me throw my
life into Bitcoin and for me
initially that was me I'm I'm this is
2021 around when I did the nft um I was
heavy heavy and less the bigcoin cuz I'm
I'm foming Bitcoins I don't want a 2X I
want a 10x I want to be rich you know I
want a Lambo and I went into SS
I put probably three three $350,000 in
alts specifically at had a few guys in
the crypto world I I just came back from
Dubai with like 10 crypto
multi-millionaire so that didn't help
and yeah they gave me a list of alts I
remember just blind trusting it w and
they didn't me like these were huge
coins hu huge uh market caps um in the
you know eight n figures which coins did
you put in I remember I definitely was
in Luna but I sold before it went CRA I
sold before it went crazy um I know I
was in
Tron uh I man I don't remember all the
names now I think snow or like snow Yeah
snow or like alpha or something just
weird ass coins dude none of
like the more credible ones like eth or
a I I stayed away from eth Bitcoin
specifically I stayed away from all the
ones kind of a cardono I was in you're
an A and this is the thing that I
up on I did it at like 65 Bitcoin so
it's just pay so you put 350 Grand at
the top of the market and I realized
that the the market isn't something you
try to beat I think the market is
something that you consistently put
money in things that you think will work
long term yes and I just I don't try to
time it anymore so now my whole thing is
like cash in crypto I'm really against
stocks in real estate initially I think
you're against stocks in real estate why
yeah when I was in my path to a million
bucks I think I was like oh yeah like I
have 200 Grand let me put 50 Grand in
stocks my 8% it's just not how I think
now I look at crypto less as an
investment and more as a good place to
literally store cash to store value um
and I mean I think people would agree
with that I was in I was telling you the
story I was in London this random girl
stole my ledger oh yeah and I
was like this she just like but
she didn't know I could just go home I
remember she texted me she's like I hope
you didn't e it it got stolen i'm like
and so wait Wait So Random woman
stole your Ledger yeah I was like I was
like half dating this girl how much did
you have on it I mean at least a few six
probably like at the time 260
270 and so were you able to get a seed
for a yeah thank God
anyone watching this feel cold
storage keep that seed keep the seed
phas safe take it from me flying home
was scary man cuz I went two weeks not
knowing cuz like I there was a side of
me that said she could have cracked into
it I was like man if this girl
cracked into that and somehow got
it I would have it would have pissed me
off a lot yeah because it's only secured
by a pin that's but I I researched it if
it gets hit three times so they Tred
three times it resets yeah but yeah I
got home typed in the seed phrase bought
two new ones good good deal and I have a
really good safe setup now uh I I talked
to some guys now I'm better I saw
actually you have a huge safe upstairs
safey is it is it bolted yeah big safe
guy big safe guy and big gun guy no one
get any ideas oh you have guns here as
well I I have guns everywhere that's
good that's crazy I a car desk room one
bathroom have you ever be in a position
where you have to use the gun no thank
God but I have definitely had some
scares I have like a I mean you hear you
any door that opens my apartment there's
a ring in every room I have office and
bedroom cuz I don't really around
to sleep I had just stop I Walker a year
ago this weird ass guy yeah he
pulled up to my apartment twice just
weird so I'm I don't around with
safety especially the space I'm in just
I'm in a very I'm a very robbable person
yeah are you are you always armed yeah I
mean I don't cuz in Florida you can you
just have to I mean any anytime I I've
every time I'm out and about I'll always
have a gun yeah just don't have any
ideas don't get any ideas I have
a safe and I have a gun beautiful
Tiffany I just got this thing but yeah I
mean um that's my big thing and I was
even saying the the whole grass is not
greener in crypto the grass isn't
greener in this random thing like I was
even talking my my CEO in one of my
businesses today he brought up trying to
do this completely different thing it's
it's similar some competitors doing it
I'm like dude what's the goal we're
trying to make money and what do we need
to do to do that fulfill with our
customers and it's super simple we're
already making a ton of money let's just
do it 10x and that's the thing is it's
it's so easy to look at the one thing
someone else is doing um and look at
Tate everyone be like oh my God Tate's
making so much money from World let me
create my own real there's so many
little issues that you don't see behind
the scenes that he had to overcome that
I've overcome that any entrepreneurs
overcame what are your hardest
challenges I mean I think anyone's
hardest challenge ultimately is their
themselves and their focus because if
you're super disciplined and you're just
a beast it's so hard to to lose so so
you say discipline would be like the
most important trait for Success
discipline right now I was telling my I
always tell my team like I I'll
with them a bit to show them how
much of a demon I am I could go for
off all of I really I've I've set up now
over the last 12 months such a good
leadership team my e-com site I have
ahead and now we're about to start
acquiring stores actually and the stores
that I'm bringing in I'm not even going
to have to run I have a media buyer
full-time I have a manager full-time
fulfillment teams full-time so it it's
come to the point now customer support
team that I have managers on every
business and I always tell I told this
to one of my buddies he's a pretty big
business as well he's in a venture
capital World a bit different but he has
a startup and I said I think once you're
pass seven figures in Revenue you need
to be able to close your eyes have an
idea and have someone who can make it
happen cuz when you have that you're
going to be in such a higher leverage
situation than someone who's in your
exact same spot but he's in the
day-to-day stressing out finishing the
document doing all this dumb right
a guy like musk he went
Twitter's up I think like 25% since he
acquired it the guy made2 billion and he
probably didn't do anything he probably
walked in I think he brought the toilet
in or the sink the sink it was the sink
I he walked into Twitter headquarters he
took a flight on his jet he walked in
dropped the sink probably had three or
four meetings fired everyone fired
everyone made made 5 hours of decisions
and he made2 billion like do you want to
make $2 billion an hour cuz I do yeah
yeah yeah and that's my perspective is
the grass is green where you water it
really focus on doing what you do really
well right and you need to
decide if you're in a good Avenue or not
that's the one caveat where if you're in
a bad Avenue like if you're a
garbage man like you're not going to be
rich like it's just very hard but as
long as your time isn't TI to you making
money you're good I think that's the
biggest Factor yeah and you you
mentioned you know you kind of got
wrecked in crypto oh the Al I I think I
lost 80% and I remember just like being
like I think it was like 40 Grand
and I got out yeah that's crazy so you
going back in like do you have a plan
for the next B now just just Bitcoin
just Bitcoin smart that's very so my
thing is now I don't care to make a lot
of money from it I want to get like in
my eyes Bitcoin will hit 100K and it's
like do I want my money in cash and
watching that happen or would I rather
pretty much 50/50 would I rather be 50%
in crypto and know that it'll hit 100K
so my perspective is I don't want to be
in it too hard cuz I want to be able to
if it drops to 5K 4K I want to be I want
to be able to eat that and laugh
and giggle buy more you would you won't
ever you won't seeing look a drop like
that but I know I wouldn't sell cuz I
that's my whole perspective right now is
I'm prepared for it to get wrecked cuz I
know I think inevitably within 10 Years
it'll be at 100K and that's that's going
to be my bio of probably like 75 80% but
who knows right now that's very
conservative I'd say though 10 years 100
I'm you know one thing I've been also
telling this to my team a lot I think
it's really comforting and I'm like you
don't need to have the plan for
everything and I think that's okay and I
love that just the idea of like you
don't need the full big picture plan yet
and that's okay and that's my thing with
investing too it's like dude if some if
we get Alien Invasion tomorrow
everything's going to crypto I'm running
dude but at the same time you know if
the government if us announces a
full ban on crypto I'd have I'd have to
rethink the decision you know hopefully
it doesn't happen well at least your
completely Diversified you know you have
a real business and I always tell you
like I really am not scared now of
losing everything I think getting over
that crumble is like really nice right
right when you get over the idea of like
what have happen What would happen if I
lose everything I think that's the
ultimate confidence in yourself if you
lost everything how would you start
again I think instantly if I right now
lost everything I'd Outreach probably a
100 businesses that are similar to what
I did and I would just say let me come
in and just be your like operator like
let me operate it I'll say like don't
pay me give me 30 days if I don't make
you an extra like 100k like fire me and
then I would just come in they would
like holy this kids a genius yeah
I'd probably do that then I would go to
like fractional Consulting for each of
them and then when I have like a mill or
two I'd probably start a startup
startups and E exiting a business is the
move like if I could reset right now I
like what I did because it produced a
lot of cash flow it let me live a really
fun life but like when you know in a few
years you can sell a business for 100
Mil and like holy if I just hustle
for three years straight I could sell
for 100 Mil you get a sense of like
motivation and discipline like like no
other and I think part of wanting to
work hard is enjoying what you do and
enjoying the Outlook of where you're
going to get to and that's why I love
the idea of starting a big business
because like uh Becker and hrus is a
good example I think they were only at
like I want to say it was like 12 mil AR
it wasn't that insane but they're
selling for a 10x multiple they're
selling for 120 mil this guy 35 like
all the nonsense business model
YouTube like 35 years old 120 mil into
his bank account pay his taxes 100 Mil
left over whatever like that's fun
that's nice to be 35 with the 100 Mil
and then you start breaking it down
realize like wait it's it's not that
difficult you just have to learn how to
get a business to like 10 mli year in
Revenue maybe net 30 40% and just do it
with a business that has major
Enterprise Value so definitely figuring
out how to produce the cash flow is the
harder part that's why I like that I
learned that first it's difficult I
didn't no one funded me no one gave me
money I had sketchy points that crypto
when that crypto thing happened
I was like um but yeah what's your
exit strategy you want to sell the
companies right now the reason I'm in
mentoring in social media is because I
like the idea of having an audience I
think it's one of the highest lever
things there's four keys of he says this
media time money there's one more media
time money and trip to people so all
four of those levers are levers of
Leverage you know you can be super the
analogy he gives is you could be super
skinny and meak but you have a super
long pole and you can pull that pull and
it's just as hard for you than something
a super short pool that's super strong
cuz he's with this like you know the
whole idea of like pulley in Egypt how
they build the Pyramid using Leverage is
how people do amazing things and um for
me media and having a social media
presence it's hug with a t t and I don't
know what his whole situation is but
that real world sh printing yeah so it's
like I don't know what everyone else's
goal is and mine's to make a lot of
money I'm trying to make it really easy
for it to that's my thing I really don't
live life stressful anymore cuz it's I'm
doing the things now it makes life so
easy and simple to where like it's like
getting dire results just I can share it
out top I'm curious the people from prob
now trying to reach out to you yeah yeah
I don't talk to many people like it's
the same thing with like leaving I don't
leave much I hate like even lunches and
stuff it's only when I really like
meeting you guys the one meet you guys
we'll do a lunch but I I really do hate
that love you guys I hate the idea
of doing anything like out of my work
it's just not enjoyable I'm like a very
introverted person when it comes to that
you know I'll do little me and I
what advance but um yeah I don't talk to
any of them again it just doesn't relate
too well
um yeah I mean I've never done I've ever
been I'm not a big way so ask I'm a very
sponsor so how can people get in touch
with you if they want to work with you
follow you they what's the best way to
un touching you yeah I always tell
people easiest like Hub of social media
that could lead you everywhere Tik Tok
make my name with Jacob just easy to
remember um you can see my YouTube and
linkoln bio come Instagram but yeah IG
Twitter Tik Tok YouTu what all Jacob
thank you so much for coming up it's be
so fascinating um I I said at the
beginning of the conversation I just
can't believe what a different world
we're in um you know Le 16 to 23y olds
making millions I don't mean 1 million I
mean like five six million it's truly
insane it's infinite it's infinite it
literally is and you know God knows you
guys with me 10 years so that's why you
know I've really enjoyed conversations
and really appreciate you coming much
thank you br if you enjoyed this episode
please don't forget to hit the like
button and subscribe as we have a lot
more of this business CL and M